هذه المقبره بتماثيلها ومقتنياتها احدث
اكتشاف اثري في مصر لكن مع فارق بسيط وهي
انها تعود الى عام 2022 بعد الميلاد وان
مقتنياتها لا تقدر بثمن لانها اصلا عديمه
الثمن
[موسيقى]
الجار بالقطع الاثريه المزيفه منتشر في كل
انحاء العالم لكن ان يتم تزييف وتزوير
مقبره فرعونيه باكملها فهذا ابتكار جديد
ارتدعه لصوص محترفون في مصر القصه بدات
عندما رصد احد الاشخاص حركه مريبه في جبل
في مركز الفشن التابع لمحافظه بني سويف
على الفور ابلغ السلطات المختصه التي
سرعان ما شكلت لجنه فنيه لمعاينه المكان
لتقع الصدمه مقبره فرعونيه كامله بكل
مقتنياتها الاثريه وحفره عمقه 15 مترا
داخل الجبل بها ثلاث غرف وتوابيت وتماثيل
وجدران ملونه وكل ذلك مزيف وغير حقيقي
حتى النقوش اللي موجوده هنا لا تمد للاصل
بشيء سواء كان الخرطوش اللي هو الفيك ده
بيتكلم على اي كلام مناظر النقوش اللي
احنا شايفينها كلها دي كلها رسومات اتعملت
حديثا
النقوش في هذه المقبره لا تمت للحضاره
المصريه القديمه بصله كلها مقلده ومصنوعه
من البلاستيك كما ان التابوت الموجود
مصنوع من الفايب وجدران المقبره مصنوعه من
خشب الابلكاش لكن لو حقيقه الامر هنلاقي
ان تمثال برضو جبس وما فيش حاجه اثريه على
الاطلاق
اجهزه الامني تكثف من جهود البحث عن
الجنات المسؤولين عن تشييد هذه المقبره
المزيفه واتخاذ كل الاجراءات القانونيه
ضدهم كما حذرت من الوقوع في مثل هذه
العمليات المتعلقه بالاتجار بالقطع
الاثريه بشكل عام دي نصيحه يمين لكل
الطماعين ما تقعوش فريسه في ايد النصابين
لو سمحتوا هنا صبايا كبيره
عظمه القدماء المصريين تتضح من نقش
مقابرهم ودقه التصميم في تماثيلهم وثبات
اللون على جدران معابدهم حتى اليوم ولا
مجال للحديث عن قيمه ماليه لقطعه صغيره من
اثار القدماء المصريين فبعض القطع الاثريه
الحقيقيه يمتد تاريخها لخمسه الاف عام قبل
الميلاد اما مقبره بني سويف المزيفه هذه
فعمرها لا يتجاوز عاما واحدا
[موسيقى]